yes
so
hey
use them up
okay
i keep pushing from
this strong
don't hit the map stay with me
stay with me stay there
look what's going over your head stay
there center up
yep
start over here
don't make a circle
does your elbows come in
see that difference i'll go in
thank you
you're really sucky
god
now you're not gonna go backwards
watch watch him watch where he falls
okay
which way did he come from he came from
that wall
he's not he's not gonna fall there he's
fallen
through the angle i cut so okay don't
expect to go backwards
i go i go through his face boom
it's the same angle on the uh same angle
so you can see i'm here
and i go through his bit when i do a
tank on
oh i'm in the same angle okay
you're gonna go that way as you can stop
trying to sit down
and go
got it
everything that you do with your hands
so
if i go like this there's no block there
okay here
not like this
okay
so i'm going to start here
you're going to push faces here okay my
space is not here
push on my face
here come here the head relax all you're
going to do is that
okay here he goes elbow in
he's here he pushes elbow in
make sure you got a kimi okay
oh give connection connection like
swords
you don't have connection look okay
stride
so right when i feel when i if you don't
have connection i come on
you you gotta make our sword stuck you
understand
so when i feel him pushing i don't move
my hand
i drop my elbow boom okay
try it
your elbow that's your hand
no not like that your elbow
make sure your back foot is grounded
should have the same feeling on the
throne
my stomach everything
movement comes from working off your
inside
okay i'm going to you see
i'm not going like this what's wrong
with that
i didn't commit okay so i'm gonna push
you i got you because that hand is not
supposed to go there
okay oh that's it and then my center
comes
up so i don't get hit and knocked out
right
okay okay so i'm seeing this as hooking
you here like that you're out here or
you move in
and you're here you should have been
here
okay let's go
gotta find the back foot he hits the
back foot
you gotta be connected on the breadboard
you're going like this
poke hole
okay
hey
the tip
so grabs me and he's pulling me into the
stripe
this side go boom got it
and he goes
so he grabs and he's pulling me into
the strike you got it do you understand
so the technique is on the backhand this
time
okay so he goes i drop the elbow
oh you're going to grab the front side
do you understand that don't go back
because that's the side near you you see
and you pull them in so if i'm here like
this
i'm not going to grab the back side
you grab the front side boom
grab the front side oh elbow
pop he grabs the front side
i immediately put my hand there in
i have to step into the technique he'll
hold
i can go back go punch hold elbow in
step step around here yes
there you go boom go around it
good go around
okay go
i'm already moving
already moving
okay
wake up
you're not gonna do the same thing every
time
so i put my hand here because i don't
want that thing coming up in my face
but look you can clear it too
okay but watch my feet work so i'm going
around
you see my hips rotating i'm more this
hip's already on the outside okay
so i just need to position okay
get back back
didn't do it
don't do like this
boom you're you're you're in an
enclosed fight
oh my god
get backwards with your left foot
your elbow has to come in and get that
spike out of the way
what if it's a knife your mouth outside
elbow comes in come for the center line
the other elbow
step back then
i don't want to wrestle with him you
understand that
where he he feels he's got me
but i'm fencing with him okay
got it so i i just have free-for-all
shots
i have the kazushi angle got it i'm not
pushing where he can step
okay let's go
around
right
oh
you take the absorption you go into the
fall i'm pulling it a little bit
okay but i have everything in place
where
oh i can knock the hell out of you at
that position angle okay
and let's say so we go slow
boom let's say i don't get it i just get
enough all right
then boom i come in with the rest of the
position you got it
but all i'm doing now is boom finding
the clean striking name okay
those who poke through go
go slow
hey guess which part
the hat
so don't go past your target you see
that
okay everything just wants boom
just like fancy
step back yes
is
okay so if i'm doing it in fighting
right here
that's goofy as hell okay
i need to be opponent this this
is we we don't do self-defense here
but that's these pool you see that's the
tactical application
this is the drill
that's all we're doing but i've still
seen some of you
all right and you're going like this
it's a bad coke you hole on top of it
okay
but you're not taking the next step
got it one more each
all right
not the neck not the chest right